[Music]
to kind of preface this what we're going
to say is
this is technically a review in progress
for us
and it's worth caveating that it's a
different kind of review in progress
usually when we do these things we're a
little further along in our
play time with the game before we do it
however
we got this game very late i believe it
was like 48 hours before the embargo
lifted
which is tight nevertheless jordan who
is reviewing it for us
has powered through and played a
significant chunk of it and the rest of
us have also played the game
um i mean you played so much a
significant chunk of the first one
yeah the first game sorry that's what i
meant forgetting that there's three
games in this package
so and the rest of us have also played a
bunch of it um
so this discussion is different because
we're going to be talking about it
but the review itself is going to be an
ongoing process for
for for a little while we imagine
because it's what 350ish hour games
um so it'll be a while before we
finalize it but we still want to have
some sort of uh video out there that
gives our
impressions of where we're at with it
and i think that what makes it a little
easier
is we're very familiar with these games
to the point where
playing these remakes the changes are
immediately evident to us
so we have a degree of confidence in
speaking about
the things that we've played thus far
and knowing that it's not going to be
drastically different
um so with that in mind let's get into
it
and go to jordan first as our reviewer
um how are you finding it
it's really interesting because mass
effect
1 is the only mass effect game that i've
only played a single time i've played
2-3 and andromeda
multiple times but i played the first
one
like for the very first time in like
2014 2015 so like it was pretty old
at that point i'm like yeah i'm not
gonna
replay this game again the combat has
not
aged very gracefully in the
seven years since its release at least
on
xbox 360 here on the pc that
mods did a fabulous job of trying to
keep that game up to date so this is my
first time
playing mass effect 1 for a second
time and man combat's so much better
like there are other improvements in
like other places but
combat is so so much
better and i and i'm like oh i can i can
probably play mass effect 1 like a few
more times now because
like i'm not accidentally mailing
someone when someone charges in on me i
can actually strafe around a target
because the guns actually
track the geth a little bit more easily
i'm not like
running for cover and then shepard's
just awkwardly standing there
because they have to press another
button in order to crouch it's just
so much more seamless and oh my god
i love it so much yeah so as a question
for someone who has jean-luc for someone
who has
way more repeated playthroughs than
jordan
and probably more than any of us like
i've made maybe play that game twice
um do the changes that jordan brings up
as improvements to the combat um feel
significant to you too
yeah uh 300 hours according to steam and
that's not even counting
the amount of times i've played on xbox
i have played mass effect 1
so many times it's one of my favorite
games um
yeah absolutely because i i was like
just replaying it on pc
like the day before um to like capture
some footage for our
graphics comparison that we did and
switching from that
to the legendary edition changes it was
like
immediately apparent uh like the just
so like mass effect 1 uh
when you like the opening guns you get
it it's like
they were very much like bio were trying
to you know they never really made a
shooter before so they were figuring out
like
rpg mechanics into guns so like
assault rifles just had uh like this
crosshair that took up like a third of
the screen bullets would fly everywhere
you wouldn't hit
jack [ __ ] it was so bad like it took
like hours and hours and hours before
you got a gun that even like
felt somewhat decent to shoot
immediately change that it still is
like don't go into this like after
playing like mass effect 2 or 3 and
being like it's gonna feel exactly like
that
like i think the underlying uh
faults of the combat system are still
kind of present
but uh yeah just just the immediate
feel of the guns is such a vast
improvement like jordan said
you don't feel like uh you're you're
you're wrestling with it like
that's always sort of like the big
caveat with mass effect one it's like oh
man like the story is great and the
characters in the world building
maybe put it on casual and don't really
care about the combat
like i think they've it it's now in a
place where it feels like you can
actually engage with the combat and have
like
a decent time i do think it still
has like i said some flaws especially
when you get to some of the side content
where the difficulty kind of
spikes in odd places like uh some of
that enemy
ai is is is rough and some of the powers
are
wildly out of balance uh well that's the
thing i was
i was going to bring up so they've tuned
weapons like weapons feel so much better
and the fact that you're not restricted
on which weapons you can use anymore
like i can finally be the biotic with
the
sniper rifle and just like have a good
time doing that speaking of snipers
oh my god snipers are so good in this
one so
like i am terrible
at sniping in every other game and i was
like
i always see you know people talk about
being the infiltrator
um with the sniper rifle so i was like
i'm just gonna have a go and i was like
oh this is so much fun this is like
my new favorite way of playing sniper
rifles were literally
like unusable because the the sway would
be
like it's like shepard was just drunk
constantly like like it was impossible
to shoot anything unless you were on
like
like i literally cuz i played on like pc
i would like learn
how to like the timing of the sway and
like
that's how i would like use those sniper
rifles like i just got good at the
jank but like this is like oh it's just
you zoom in and you aim you just zoom in
and you shoot someone like a normal
video game
the one the one thing that i would say
though
that i still have like the biggest issue
with when it comes to combat is the
powers like you mentioned some of them
are
um overpowered but also it's because and
i know this is
you know within me is that i get used to
playing mass effect 2 and 3
where the powers like know where they're
supposed to be going like they will
curve around
yeah uh chest high crates and they will
hit the person behind
and in mass effect 1 it's like you have
to make sure it's
targeted but it's not accidentally
targeted behind because some powers
won't hit
if it's if you're if you're targeting
it's just like slightly off
and also you you pretty much have to be
like in a direct line to hit people
but saying that when you do manage to
get like a good combo going
you know i finally have liara in my
party and i finally got singularity
unlocked and
i've got tally as well so i finally feel
like i've got a decent balance party
and now i'm just like ripping through it
and it's a lot i'm going through i just
did
there and the encounters that i remember
taking me like the krogan
battle master when you're after
that guy i saw that cut scene so many
times when the first time i played the
game because it was so difficult and it
and like that encounter was just
so much better like and i know that
they've been working on like
changing up passing cancers like that
but that was the first one i did
i thought i was like oh okay it feels
fair
i have to recall like go back to the
original but i'm pretty sure
they added like a cover directly in
front of shepard when that cutscene
starts which they did not have in the
original
i'm pretty sure and i was like oh they
know they know people hated this
yeah so kind of like bring it full
circle on the combat i think
jean-luc pretty much hit the nail on the
head where
the combat is still not the main draw
of the first mass effect it's the kind
of thing that is in
i want to say a necessary evil but that
paints it in a perhaps more negative
light than i
intend it to it's the thing that kind of
it's the glue that holds the rest of it
together but the rest of it is far more
important
and the kind of um ethos and the
objective from bioware was to kind of
try and
raise the quality of the combat so it's
kind of trying to be somewhere in the
ballpark near
mass effect two and three which are
considerably better i think uh jordan
and you guys can tell me
whether you disagree but like i don't
think it gets there
but it gets high enough where you can
recommend
playing mass effect um yes yeah one as
an
entry point again yeah and that's
something i know i no longer have to
tell people just start with mass effect
2 and do the
genesis comic i can actually like tell
them it's like you can start with mass
effect
i understand that like it's like this
weird like i totally get where you're
coming from jordan but i'm also like
but there's so much good stuff in mass
effect 1 and
like we'll get into that but like that's
the most exciting thing about this
this remake for me yeah i think it's
important to note that there are
elements of the combat that because of
the nature of the review and progress
and not the combat the gameplay itself
we haven't
jordan hasn't fully been able to
experience and none of us have really
which is kind of like the different
pacing on levels
and character development and
progression oh i beat the game already
oh you've been yeah i already beat it
when have you slept
i beat it last night and then i already
started two okay then so
john lu can speak to this what what's
the uh what's that kind of change
what's the impact of that um kind of uh
the
the squashing of the level progression
is there anything
so i would say the yeah because they
change it now where
instead of going all the way up to 60
you can like squash it down to 30. you
can also go back and change that if you
prefer the classic one
um personally i found the pacing of
uh like abilities and and skills to feel
really good like i was able to get to
the end of the game and i had pretty
much gotten
i think it was like level 20 out of 30
and i had gotten pretty much
all the major skills i cared about i
maxed out my charm
uh and stuff like that so it felt it
felt like a good balance i also
felt like the combat it does the same
thing that the original mass effect does
where
like i said it starts off like man all
my equipment's garbage and by the end
you have such good equipment that you're
kind of just steamrolling
everything like i i was playing on
normal and i
i the ending boss was like kind of a
joke because i just had like the best
assault rifle in the game uh that i
bought from uh the citadel
there was a weird part in the middle um
where i was doing a couple side missions
where
the the power curve was way off what it
should have been
um and i think that's just because i
wasn't doing every single side mission
in the game so i did this one particular
one
and it like kept kicking my ass um but
that felt like a weird outlier i would
say
overall the power curve is actually like
very similar to how it was in the
original game it's just like it feels
better because like the shooting
feels good so one question you mentioned
that the boss towards the end was a bit
of a joke
um or was very easy does that take away
anything from
like the crescendo of of the actual game
because obviously
traditionally speaking you want you want
the final boss but like
in my mind i'm guessing i'm thinking
back to it and i don't remember caring
that
whether the boss was challenging or not
i remember the narrative payoff being
the main thing
is that still the case i would say so
it's hard for me to say because like i
said i've beaten this game so many times
that like
uh i don't have about i long have lost
that perspective of the first time i
just imagine you i just imagine the
shepherd that you just played being the
same shepherd who's gone through this 20
times and it's just like dead-eyed
groundhog day now and it's like
i've done this 21 times for real though
it's like i know all the dialogue i'm
just like yep if i do this i'll go there
and okay i'm gonna do this because
that'll be the optimal route to
you know get this decision um but no i i
it personally was fine to me because i
also was like i
had earned that in a sense that like i
spent all my money
buying a very specific like assault
rifle that i knew was gonna be really
really good
right and so it is that sort of like rpg
fantasy of like oh i just i bought the
best gear i should be able to steamroll
everything to some degree um but yeah i
like it
i didn't mind the the boss fight still
because again i'm i'm with you where
it's like that final boss fight is
okay it's more about like the story
that's happening around that boss fight
than the actual
fight itself yeah so so we talked about
kind of like the
bioware's uh objective being to raise
the quality of mass effect's combat
which is also the same
for its visuals which are another major
area of improvement
in mass effect 1. uh jordan
how did you how did you take the videos
what do you what do you make of the
the work done to mass effect 1 to make
it a little more visually
pleasing i say i'm of two minds with the
visuals there are some visual changes
that i
really really like i
i love what they've done with eden prime
i
had like no uh real nostalgia for its
original red sky lightning end of the
world feel and i
really enjoy what they've done changing
how it looks in the new one and
upping the appearance of certain
characters especially your alien squad
mates the
details on garris's face is just
really really good but then on like
the other side there are some moments
where i'm like man they just applied
like
a little too much like
lighting to this scene like especially
for some of the
human characters that are darker
what is going on with that anderson in
certain scenes like the
lighting is just i don't know maybe
maybe it's the lighting a little bit off
or some of the texture is not working
with the lighting i can't really tell
i'm not a game developer so i
don't know too much about it but it just
looks
off and i'm like it's yeah it's a little
one
at some point it's like has a he when
you're when you first meet him in the
citadel embassies like he has
a weird silver sheen and it's clearly
like coming from the reflections within
the citadel because when
later on he his skin tone is like back
to normal but it
there are those like moments where the
lighting maybe just doesn't
cooperate with the human models too much
it does just look a little bit jarring
what did you what do you make of the
kind of changes
um visual changes john luke uh i am
very very mixed on the whole thing uh i
agree with jordan where it's like i
think all the aliens
look great because i think it preserves
the original spirit and just like
cleans and elevates them same thing with
like armor any any sort of like clothing
like it all just looks really
sharp and clean you go back to that
original game and
they look like 720p textures blown up
and they're just
like oh they're rough to go back to the
overall tonal change though
in terms of like just like the set
dressing and the lighting is so
dramatically different and i i don't
think i like
a lot of it it's like a good example
that i think is actually like okay it's
like uh
the presidium in on the citadel if you
look at that and you compare it to the
original
it's very different it it is it is more
different than i think you would think
it is
um but it looks a lot like mass effect
3's version of the presidium so it feels
like they're trying to line it
up with how it looked like in the later
games and i
kind of started to realize like i feel
like that is
probably the lens that they made a lot
of the changes for was trying to
cohesively line up one
to aesthetically kind of match two and
three more so
for example the wards uh look very
different because the sky box is no
longer this like
you know dark city with like all the
lights of the the citadel it's now very
bright
and it gives that whole area a different
feel uh a lot of the harsh
lighting is uh is gone
so like there would be areas where like
characters were just like
bathed in like a blue or reds and that
is significantly toned down
i do feel like it kind of loses some of
the unique
visual identity that that first game had
um
it it gives it a very different look and
i'm curious to see how everyone feels
about it because i think everyone's
going to have kind of their own
take if they prefer it or not um and you
know
obviously i i have the perspective of
having played so much mass effect 1 that
i'm like so accustomed to how that looks
but uh i think it does ruin some shots
like there
there is a there's a scene with um
saren um after eden prime
and they have this scene where he's he's
basically like
looking straight at the camera and he's
kind of got his uh hand
uh covering his his face but you can see
his eye
shining through in the original in the
new one the lighting is different and
you can't see his eye at all
so like the whole framing of that shot
doesn't work anymore in the original
everything is very much bathed in
darkness you can't really see much
outside of like
saren and benezia there and the new one
they've lit everything so now you can
see
the background and you can see this sort
of like kind of stark empty environment
that
you weren't really supposed to see so
you get a lot of weird things like that
where it's like by by trying to kind of
brighten
up you you see more of the flaws
in some of like the environment that
they were kind of trying to mask
with that very uh sort of like intense
saturated lighting that they were going
for
uh it's yeah it's just i don't know
it's so different and it's closer to one
and two
but like i or sorry it's closer to two
and three but i think it's just like one
had such a unique
look because of that lighting that it it
does feel like it it kind of got lost
i think the thing that you picked up on
that is really interesting to me
is like the the eye the visual identity
of mass effect
1 in its original form that was created
almost by accident
by like the i don't know about the
limitations but like the implementation
of
of like the lighting systems back then
like those a lot of that stuff felt like
it wasn't intended to be that way but
because it was that way
it became a stylistic choice that we
associated with mass effect
like those rooms that you walk into and
this character is just bathed in a red
light
and you look around the room and you're
like this probably isn't the way they
wanted it
but you remember it in your head that
way it's iconic and that shot of saren
with his eye
glowing that way i don't know if they
meant it that way
but it's certainly something has been
lost because of it
um at the same time there are other
things that i don't know maybe
my memory is like bad but like sometimes
i'll go into an environment and be like
oh snap i don't remember that or i've
forgotten it and the fact that i'm
seeing it in this way is so powerful
like on eden prime for example the the
reaper in the distance that's
like as you're approaching it's like
lifting off so slowly
i when i played that trailing after yeah
exactly
and like that was like genuinely like
stopped me in my tracks
and that was the first place that i
pulled up the photo mode on
and spent a good 15-20 minutes lining up
an amazing shot of like shepherd
looking like from a really low angle
shot looking up at this
towering goliath of a thing and i was
like that's
really cool and i i know that like my
memory is rubbish but i don't think it
stood out with such stark contrast back
in the day
because like in the same way that um the
some of the weird technicalities of
lighting in the old version created
iconic moments
they also could have lost iconic moments
and those ones are being created now in
the new
version like that feels like the new
iconic a new iconic moment for me
it wasn't in the original i will agree
to that on some level because i
i the final planet you go to um
ilos is like this ruined
city and i remember it looking really
cool in mass effect 1 but not
really fully understanding like exactly
what they were going for with it there's
a level of clarity to how it looks now
that i was i found myself looking around
a lot more and appreciating like
oh this is like a city and i'm in this
like
kind of courtyard area here and i found
myself like kind of
getting more what like they were trying
to go for with the environment in a way
that i
didn't uh so yeah like i it is
that's why it's like it's a mixed bag
because it is like this
it feels like some things maybe are
highlighting more of the original vision
that the limitations
weren't able to capture or and and also
like to be fair like
for all my gripes it is a lot of fun to
just like see these environments
in kind of a new way with a new coat of
paint like it did bring up this like
renewed nostalgia uh where it's like oh
like you know seeing vermeyer like this
lush
with like the water and the plants like
it
it does it does capture a certain like
spirit to it so so those are the two
main
big changes in a lot of ways the game's
the same for the
most part the rest of it um so with that
in mind
like lucy how does the rest of the game
hold up the things that people
know and mass effect and love mass
effect for the writing the
characterization how is that holding up
for you
um all these years later um has the
passage of time
kind of dulled any of the impact of that
at all for you
honestly no and so we i mean as a team
have been revisiting sort of mass effect
law etc
quite a lot recently um and
even though i've been spending all our
time just re-watching cut scenes and
kind of doing that to
i don't know like get ready for
legendary edition
even when i'm in the game and it's my
shepherd talking to tally
and it's my tally and you know she's
explaining the
the plight of the um the quarians
and you know their relationship with the
guest it's still so impactful
and i'm genuinely like it's it's so
funny because it's like a game i've
seen and played so many times that it's
like even now when i'm going around the
sit down that's like oh
this is the bay where i get to go see
garrus like oh i get to go see rex
um and immediately like the first thing
i did was go to uh
get liara and you know those characters
are still
incredible and i think like just kind of
going back and seeing them at the
beginning
knowing what you're about to go through
kind of makes it for me even more
impactful
i think if you are new to mass effect
um i think you're still gonna be in it
for a fantastic ride like that
opening when it's you know shepard like
staring out the window and
you get the brief kind of explanation of
what's happening and you're thrown into
the fire
is is still incredible and you know our
friend simon
is playing and he's texting us at the
same time he's like i'm into this like
i've just spent two hours
walking around the citadel talking to
everyone because i just want to know
more about this world and
that is the thing that bioware does so
right it's like in
all of their games especially a mass
effect where the world is right
and the world building is right like it
has rules it has
law it has history that's so rich and so
dense and so whatever
story you tell in it especially one
that's as
like just well done as mass effect it's
it's just gonna work
and it does and it's still like some of
the lines is just still
so iconic and still so good and time
hasn't tarnished them at all
so just to wrap up kind of the
discussion around um
uh mass effect legendary edition jordan
um just kind of like summation of your
impressions so far
and obviously you played it once i
believe you said but you haven't come
back to it
is it is it something that you're glad
that you're able to experience again
and how does it make you feel about
the prospect of playing two further
games that you're more familiar with
i say i'm really enjoying it it feels
almost like i'm playing through parts of
it again because i
played it only once and that was seven
years ago so it's been a really long
time so i am
able to play through parts of mass
effect 1 and be like i have
no idea what's supposed to happen next
i'm all right i'm going to novaria next
this is going to be cool i
can't remember anything that happens
during this mission
i think it works to attract a new
audience
in i'm enjoying it a lot more than i
ever did primarily because of the
improvements to combat
and it's really i think it's going to be
really cool to just
get a better grasp of how certain
aspects
of the original mass effect evolved into
the rest of the trilogy and
influenced other bioware games like
dragon age seeing things like
helping garris track down a doctor
getting the armor for rex become the
loyalty missions
how paragon and renegade choices evolve
with interrupts and stuff like that in
the later games it's
cool to go back now and play the
original
mass effect and be like oh there were a
lot of
things in mass effect 2 and 3 that i
liked that i didn't really see in
the mass effect 1 the first time i went
through because i was kind of
not enjoying the combat so i was not
enjoying the game as a whole and i was
just kind
of like trying to get through it and now
that i can kind of
stop and enjoy my time and go through it
and do more
missions because i'm enjoying the
shooting aspect of it
i'm noticing a lot of really cool things
about the game that
will inform what the rest of the trilogy
evolves into
awesome yeah i think i think we're all
pretty excited about
going into the next few games as well
because
those games are considerably better in
my mind
and that's where all the all the things
that the
the mass effect um the first mass effect
kind of laid down as a foundation
really start firing on all cylinders um
and really they as michael heim would
say hit different
with that in mind are there any things
that you've picked up on as
you know standing out as being
particularly egregious in
and not being good i mean for me a lot
of the a lot of it is like
some of it is like fundamentally what
mass effect is
like uh some of the planet exploration
stuff and that kind of stuff
like it's not great um but is there
anything really egregious that
is worse now and was in the last game or
because of the changes other than
perhaps like aesthetic and stuff and uh
presentation changes is anything that
really sticks out that
you feel like needs to be brought up
just in case people
are going into it expecting a perfect i
mean no game's perfect but
needs to be raised yeah i would say kind
of to what you said like it's
i think more a byproduct of
what mass effect was when it released in
2007
like the way that liara kind of just
throws herself at you like the romances
in general
in the first mass effect game like they
do not
match what they will become in mass
effect 2 and mass effect
3. so i think if you play the first mass
effect and you're like
i can't believe people are like oh i
love romancing garrus like because
the romances in this mass effect game
just aren't good at all it's like
give it another game i swear they get
significant
the jump in quality from one to two is
very
yeah i i did learn this romance and i
was like oh this dialogue is
bad like bioware has come a really long
way
with that stuff and yeah maybe that
that's for me probably the most thing is
just like
some some dialogue is is feels maybe
like a little stiff a little unnatural
in spots um
some of the pacing that that game does
take a while to like really get going
you know like you
have eaten prime and you have the
citadel and that stuff's all great in
its own way but it takes a while before
you like properly get your ship and kind
of get the freedom
to explore also uh i think
as much as i appreciated back in the day
like how
methodical it was where it's like you
need to fly back to the citadel and then
you
you land and then you gotta take the
elevator down to the you know
c-sec and then you can like fast travel
in mass effect two and three you can
just fast travel
to any spot on the citadel immediately
when you go there so like
stuff like that eventually grates on you
especially if you're doing a lot of side
quests and you're going back to the
citadel like you will get
very comfortable with that hanger and
that elevator it is still
like why is there not a
exactly like that's all they needed to
do to fix it and
like little stuff like that where you're
like okay they ironed these kinds of
quality of life stuff in in later games
like that's
that stuff's still present they don't
fundamentally change any of that
okay cool and then jordan apologies only
speak for you a bit here but you've put
up your
um review in progress which is basically
early impressions of mass effect 1 but
um the plan is for you to continue
playing and play through the entire
uh collection and then update your
review and finalize the score right and
then
we'll probably knock out a video review
with all that
finalized um which may be john luke
likely jean-luc
editor
sorry john you're going to be on one
yeah
warmed up your fingers he loves it he
loves yeah
i'll do mass effect stuff all day i
don't care
great there you have it mass effect
legendary edition
cool
[Music]
you